so I saw another clip this week and I
wanted to talk about the really the life
cycle that I see with only fans models
so only fans and porn workers tend to
have this life cycle they tend to do the
sex work and during the sex work they
say they have no regrets no their family
issues did not contribute to this and
they just tend to really die on the hill
that there's no regrets one example I
saw of this was I actually met um Sky
Brie when I was at no jumper a couple of
months ago and when I talked to her she
seemed to have no qualms with doing
porn until now fast forward six months a
year later she says she can't do it
anymore because she found a guy that she
loves and a lot of times what these
women want is they want to erase the
past and have no consequences for their
poor decisions you know I say do what
you're going to do um preferably not
porn if it was up to Pearl I would ban
porn but this is not Pearl's world but
don't complain about the consequences
later life is about choices and
trade-offs some women do sex work and
decide that they're going to cash out
young and die alone but what a lot of
times women want to do is they want to
do porn and have a happy ending later
and that is not the case for most of
them even if you watch porn stars that
do get married like Mia Khalifa or Lana
roads they do get men interested in them
but the problem is they are so
sensitized that they cannot stay with
that guy so here is a clip of a woman
getting rejected on whatever podcast
because she did porn let's pull it up I
actually like you like I would I
literally have said like I would sign an
NDA and like never like let people know
about our relationship but like I
actually like actually like you so
confirm or deny are you a pathological
liar but I'm not a [__] anymore I don't
do porn anymore but I I literally said I
would stop being a [__] for you and I
literally stopped porn listen you're an
Interactive point but the fact that
you've done porn and it was a hiccup it
is a 100% a deal breaker like but I said
I'm sorry and I literally quit being a
thought your thank you for your apology
and like my pussy's like great I accept
I accept your apology for doing porn
Okay um yeah it's just not going to
happen Brian why like because I used to
be a
[__] like used to you still
[Music]
are she's so funny actually the one girl
has to chime in you still are yeah guys
you don't get to erase the past you
don't and you know there are things that
men will Overlook men have increasingly
accepted more and more and more in the
last hundred years it used to be
required that you were a virgin on your
wedding night now under five Partners is
considered a good deal for men today I
don't make the rules I just tell you
what they are and I'm sorry if you do
porn the odds are that you are not going
to get married the odds are not in your
favor even women that did not do porn
the odds of them getting married and
staying married and HP having that
happily ever after is actually slim to
none so the comment section chimes in
and they said I don't see an issue with
a casual Night Out many women past 19
aren't virgins anyway they may as well
have had three or four of you before so
why not have some fun the next comment
says there is no such thing as used to
be a [__] that's about as accurate as I
used to be white or I used to be tall or
I used to be Spanish and ladies this is
how men see it men do not forgive your
past you know God can forgive you but
men do not have to vad one du beat she's
finally realizing there are consequences
to her selfish actions this is
ironically if not comically the epitome
of f around and find out and guys I I
think I would be lying if I said that
men of the past never accepted sex work
you know I I've heard of women that used
to be strippers that got married right
I've absolutely heard of this I've heard
of this too high value men however men
are increasingly watching the men of the
past and watching the outcomes that
happened for the men that wied up [__]
I'll give you an example so many men
watched Kanye wife up Kim Kardashian now
Kim Kardashian is not wife material she
does not have the ability to get married
and stay married this is not a knock on
Kim Kardashian but I don't know how you
could say that someone that's been
married three times has the ability to
be a good wife and mother so many men
watched what happened when they picked
the good-looking chick that had dabbled
in sex work before and the outcomes that
it led for Kanye now you see yay
fighting for his kids in the Public
Square in the public eye he's
complaining that his wife is letting his
children be on Tik Tock he is
complaining about the schools his wife
is sending his children to he still pays
astronomical amounts of child support
and men will ask themselves if this is
the outcome for a billionaire what are
the outcomes for me men are not looking
for marriage in relationships like they
used to and they're putting up with less
and less and less